one of the most famous Wizards
a student this charm protecting his
friends when guardian Leviosa
they are real people that's so cool
is it is it Rion or is it Ryan r-i-o-n
how do you pronounce that Ryan stop
playing to watch me hey thanks for
watching appreciate you being here
hanging out actually all you guys that
are here right now man thanks everybody
oh no oh no I really need to pay
attention okay wait use Ventus to blow
it away
I love how it shows you the little path
right there
oh he got a hit in on me though
okay can we move let's move over here oh
it's kind of guiding me through this
battle okay the monster book of monsters
can charge at opponents from a distance
look the troll is distracted by the
monster book of monsters alright
now is the time to strike back
the atmospheric charm deals heavy single
Target damage
oh that's cool
your next card is shown here
oh wait am I like M I'm in the battle
now
I probably shouldn't have moved over
there but
let's try and play this
there we go
okay so I'm down to eight move cards
all right let's try it let's try this
one again that seemed to work pretty
well
atmosphere
I don't understand what they meant by
the new card
like how do I
oh I see it now then it moves over
gotcha
William how's it going welcome in
yeah you unlock you can you can duel
each other Jay that's right
you can duel there's like a whole PVP
system
okay first clear Rewards
spiders oh my goodness we got the
spiders card
use this card to summon a cluster of
spiderlings no way
and then we got some gold
acromantula Venom and troll a troll
summon
oh then it's gonna it's gonna tell me
here what we got anyway all right
all right all right all right
oh and then you have like the DPS
numbers down here
attack range medium damage interval 2.3
oh my goodness man so this is gonna get
this is gonna get really deep at high
level
there's gonna be a lot of nuance to this
there was a bottle of acromantula Venom
at the Target area dealing damage over
time
that I I see that could be pretty
powerful let's watch the tutorial video
oh wait didn't let me watch oh I wish I
was trying to click to watch the video
wait what's going on with that feather
that was impressive you must have
practiced a lot
not really I'm just naturally telling
okay you can join different servers you
oh you can using the same account I wish
I was that good
yes well I'm sure you'll get better I
did not know that
you just have to like go back and forth
right I'm on the opal eye server that's
where I'm at practice
building Club is the place to do it
doing Club if you like let's go afraid
I'm ready for our dueling tutorial
we already met I'll give it a try
dude she didn't even remember us wow
wow she did not even remember us you
guys
talk to Cassandra then challenge her yes
let's go
Kenyan and Erica hello
this is so crazy man I love that we
could just you could see everybody in
here
uh Draco or anybody else who's been
playing this game for a while anybody
know if this if it has controller
support
if I connect the controller to my iPhone
would it work
I love to play this with a controller I
feel like a lot of it's touch touch
heavy though
check your cards okay
this is your currently equipped deck
tap here to configure
this is the deck used in battle
here are the Spells you've already
learned drag them into your deck
okay so your deck is three six like
eight cards I guess that's what you
start with
all right so we'll put that one up here
put that one up here that one up here
you build your first deck all right
now equipped Beatles burden I don't know
what that was
you ever tried it
I'm I'm afraid to try it since it took
so long to get things working but I'll
definitely try it after the Stream
all right I'm ready to challenge her
nice Moon lace made a different one
or joined a different one all right talk
to Cassandra then Challenger
[Applause]
wait I don't need to change it I already
just set that up didn't I
okay my deck or match I think that's all
that I can do from right there
I thought we were dueling Cassandra
although summoning the troll requires a
high number of magic points it has a lot
of health and can withstand a lot of
damage on the front line
all right so they're still kind of
guiding us through all of these
all right so I wonder what that red
just showing us who he's gonna attack
oh and he put out the spiders no way but
see now we can't do anything I mean I
guess we could move like over here
your opponent Summit a swarm of spiders
the troll can only attack one unit at a
time and will be quickly overrun try
countering with acromantula Venom
wait acromantula Venom on spiders
it works I guess it works oh now he's
gotta troll out no way this time your
opponent released a troll let's give
them a taste if they're a medicine and
use spiders to deal with the troll
okay
right there spiders
follow the spiders
all right now we actually have some more
things though
so let's see should I like run over here
oh no okay I think we're on our own now
oh my goodness
I think I think we're on our own
atmosphere
yeah let's let's get another troll out
all the trolls are fighting dude this is
this is crazy
get some more spiders out
oh can I move like can I get out of that
we can nice oh but it follows you
we almost got him
dude
I think I'm really gonna like this man
it's early it's early I haven't got to
like the micro transaction stuff yet but
I can see this battle system being
really fun
especially once you get to like some of
the higher level decks and stuff
myself
2V1 come on
two against one how is that fair that's
what I was saying dude
oh
that's what I'm saying two against two
I'm on opalai yeah yeah you'll need a
partner
yeah Robin oh Robin's in Gryffindor too
let's go
Robin's the Quidditch player right
yeah Robin's cool
Robin's like my first friend I feel like
except for Ivy but Ivy's currently
missing
oh my gosh we're just we're just in it
this time huh
yeah get the troll in right away to give
me that defense oh no that monster look
though man
can your spells Miss I wonder like if
you don't
let's get one on Cassandra right there
oh I didn't mean to move that
whoa wait what the heck is heck is crab
and Goyle out here
oh my gosh we just we just destroyed
them I think it's meant to be easy
did man we just destroyed them great
teamwork Robin and retro
you're not just hopeless as you look oh
she is not happy
we met
my name is he forgot two we met before
that Cassandra we bet before that
you again if you're up for it oh I'd
like that we're up for it Cassandra and
I'll be ready we're up for it
if you aim outside where the enemies are
at it'll Miss uh okay and they can walk
away from the attacks gotcha
yeah this is this is
we're early we're early but this is a
lot of fun